[Aplausos]
el deporte siempre ha estado ligado a
nuestras vidas
recuerdo con mucho cariño en la ciudad
donde nací y los teques que los niños
donde yo vivía jugaban pelotica de goma
y yo era malísimo jugando pelotica de
goma esto traía como consecuencia que
nunca me escogían para jugar la única
manera de que yo pudiera jugar era
llevar la parada
eso se traduce en tener que esperar mi
turno para armar un equipo y así poder
jugar
eso me frustraba muchísimo pero un día
mis padres super aventureros deciden que
nos vamos a vivir a mérida
y en ese estado lo único que se juega es
fútbol
gracias a dios tenía algunas habilidades
intrínsecas para este deporte
después mis padres les provocó irse a
vivir a mi querida barquisimeto en
barquisimeto se juega muchísimo béisbol
pero también se juega a fútbol y ahí me
desquité jugaba demasiado era súper
fiebrú dow llegué a jugar en tres
equipos al mismo tiempo en el equipo del
colegio era el capitán en una academia
muy famosa que se llamaba miguel plan y
en el equipo del estado lara
pero para allá para jugaba literalmente
sin exagerar todos los días
futbolito en la calle donde vivía y en
la cancha santelena recuerdo clarito y
hay un episodio que marcó mi vida porque
estamos jugando un intercolegial y
recuerdo que lo único que decía el
técnico del equipo contrario era marquen
al número 6 marquen al número 6 y yo era
el 8
no mentira yo era el 6 o sea como te
puedes sentir tú si el técnico del
equipo contrario lo único que dice es
que te marquen a ti o sea yo ese día me
sentía en las nubes
me sentía el mejor jugador del mundo o
sea lo que quiero decirte es que tenía
ciertas habilidades o sea sabía jugar
para estar en tres equipos en la
selección de lara tenía habilidades
pero cuando llegaba el momento clave en
los momentos cumbres me paralizaba
mi cuerpo decía que sí pero mi mente
decía que no
luego conocí este cuando fue amor a
primera vista
me enamoré apasionadamente de esa
disciplina deportiva me encantaba tenía
ciertas habilidades también que me
ayudaron a destacar más rápidamente en
la academia ganaba después en el estado
ganaba y eso me hizo clasificar a mi
primer nacional que fue en san felipe
estado yaracuy recuerdo que voy a mi
primer nacional
mi familia me acompañó estaban sentados
en una tribuna viéndome y me dio miedo
escénico
me desconcentré comencé a verlos a ellos
en la tribuna y me ganaron fácilmente me
eliminaron recuerdo que lloré como un
niño bueno era un niño pero lloré
muchísimo y estaba frustrado y les dije
saben que no quiero que me vengan a ver
más y eso hicieron año siguiente sigo
evolucionando gano en la academia vuelvo
a ganar en el estado y clasificó mi
segundo nacional esto fue en san juan de
los morros estado guárico voy mi primer
combate ganó segundo ganó tercero ganó
cuarto ganó y clasificó a la final que
era el día domingo
en ese entonces la potencia del té
cuando venezolano
era el estado anzoátegui el estado en su
arte aquí era donde estaban los mejores
té con vistas venezolanos como carlos
rivas arlindo gouveia adriana carmona el
presidente de la federación de té cuando
de venezuela era un coreano o es un
coreano que se llama yonki king tenía el
mejor gimnasio allá y eran muy
organizados cuando iban a los nacionales
agarraban una tribuna completa con
pancartas inmensas tambores trompetas
hacían mucha bulla y me intimidaba a
todo el mundo los que con distas
utilizaban protectores negros y recuerdo
el domingo estar sentados y cómo están
ustedes esperando mi turno y se escucha
en el parlante prevenido álvarez ortiz
versus no recuerdo el nombre del joven
vamos a ponerle pedrito pérez lo que sí
recuerdo es ansuátegui
y todavía se me eriza la piel
es impresionante el sentimiento de miedo
y de impotencia que me embargó ese día
sin haber movido un dedo ya yo había
perdido
recuerdo que comencé a bajar lentamente
las escaleras para dirigirme al ring
comienza el combate y no me podía mover
estaba en pánico
quién crees que gano
gracias por lo que me toca
no obviamente ganó un swap
año siguiente
sigo entrenando sigo destacando en la
academia vuelvo a ganar en el estado y
clasificó para mi tercer nacional
hoy ganó el primer combate el segundo
tercero y cuarto clasificó a otra final
el día domingo sentado esperando mi
turno
por el parlante prevenido álvarez ortiz
lara
versus era otro nombre pongámosles juan
garcía lo que sí era igual era
ansuátegui
y dios tiene un sentido del humor tan
impresionante
pero me vuelve embargar el mismo las
mismas emociones pánico
sin mover un dedo ya había perdido
vuelva a bajar las escaleras en trance
total no sé ni dónde estoy llego al ring
comienza el combate y no me puedo mover
fíjense las dos medallas de oro más
fáciles que se han ganado en la historia
del té cuando venezolano se las ganaron
contra mí
y no tengo ni idea porque se están
riendo porque a mí no me da risa
para nada hoy en día le doy gracias a
dios porque todo eso me impulsó a
prepararme para hoy acompañar a las
personas a superar esas creencias que
les impiden lograr sus sueños cuando
eran niños soñaba con ser jugador de la
selección de mi país no lo logré como
jugador pero sí como su coach
motivacional
ahora mirando en retrospectiva me puedo
dar cuenta como a esta altura todavía se
sigue subestimando el trabajo mental y
emocional no solo en los atletas sino en
cualquier persona que decide ir tras una
gran meta
y ahí también aprendí que ese es un
trabajo constante de día a día de seguir
entrenando porque lo vivo el día en la
selección cuando ganamos o cuando nos
toca seguir aprendiendo
pues el ser humano no vive al nivel de
sus capacidades vive es al nivel de sus
creencias
y ahí van a ver las medallas
de plata pero las más fáciles se les
ganaron otros ahora
el deporte sirve como fuente de
inspiración para la superación me
encanta como el deporte de manera
brillante ilustra ilustra los principios
y valores que se deben seguir para tener
éxito los mismos principios que se
utilizan para ser un deportista exitoso
son los mismos para ser un profesional
exitoso en el área que sea cambiará el
contexto el lenguaje pero es lo mismo
y el deporte ayuda a nuestros niños a
reforzar su autoestima su autoimagen nos
ayuda a aprender a trabajar en equipo
aún los deportes individuales tienes que
aprender a trabajar en equipo con tus
entrenadores con tu familiar les enseña
enfoque les enseña disciplina a soñar en
grande les enseña que nada en la vida
que valga la pena te la van a regalar te
lo tienes que ganar y les enseña a amar
el proceso
y es más piensa algo otra cosa que me
encanta el deporte es que sirve para
ayudar a nuestros jóvenes a salir de las
zonas vulnerables de nuestro país
aproximadamente el 90% de nuestros
jugadores provienen de zonas vulnerables
y gracias al deporte pudieron salir de
ahí no sólo ellos sino ayudar a sus
familiares y no se quedó hoy eso
trasciende en todo el país nos enseña
con el ejemplo de que es posible salir
adelante que no importa donde hayas
nacido
puedes lograr tus sueños y lo que más me
gusta es que lleguen o no a ser
jugadores profesionales esos valores y
principios nos van a moldear para
convertirse en ciudadanos que edifiquen
un gran país díganme si no es grandioso
es
y fue aristóteles quien dejó escrito que
los buenos hábitos adquiridos en la
juventud son los que marcan la
diferencia y vamos a hablar de algunos
pequeños principios que nos pueden
ayudar a reconstruir nuestra cultura
disciplina como por ejemplo la de
nuestro gran capitán tomás rincón nada
en la vida se logra sin disciplina la
motivación te ayuda a arrancar pero es
la disciplina la que te ayuda a terminar
lo que arrancas te es otro valor el de
soñar como el de nuestro máximo goleador
histórico de la vinotinto salomón rondón
nada grande se ha logrado sin una
persona soñadora otro puede ser el valor
de la constancia como el de nuestro
múltiple campeón panamericano mundial y
récord team es antonio díaz
tú no puedes lograr algo en la vida y
tantas medallas como lo ha hecho si no
tienes el valor de la constancia otro
valor el del esfuerzo
como el de nuestro
atleta nueve veces campeón mundial de
freestyle gollito estredo
el entender de que nada en la vida te lo
van a regalar te tienes que esforzar
para lograrlo el valor de la superación
como el de nuestra campeona yulimar
rojas y aquí es donde tú te das cuenta
que no es solamente lo que logra sino la
persona que te convierte en el proceso
para lograrlo y no solamente superar a
los demás sino superarte a ti mismo el
valor de la humildad como el de nuestro
campeón daniel dhers esa humildad para
entender de que siempre estamos
arrancando y no es humildad para pensar
menos de nosotros mismos sino para
pensar menos en nosotros mismos y pensar
más en los demás y no brillar para
deslumbrar sino brillar para alumbrar el
camino los que vienen de atrás
el de la resiliencia como el de nuestro
envite de las grandes ligas el gran josé
altuve el jugador más pequeño las
grandes ligas imagínate la cantidad de
obstáculos que tuvo que superar
y convertirse en el mejor jugador de las
grandes ligas valentía como el de
nuestro campeón olímpico
rubén limardo hay que ser valiente para
atreverse a querer ser campeón olímpico
y decidir ser valiente en lugar de ser
cómodo y estos son solo algunos valores
que podríamos hablar pero recuerdo estar
viendo una película con mi esposa
sentados y me impactó muchísimo porque
éste se conectó con uno de mis
propósitos de vida es la película de
jesse owens el héroe de berlin
son los juegos olímpicos de 1936 en
berlín y hay una escena en esa película
donde el comité olímpico norteamericano
está debatiendo si va o no a participar
a esas olimpiadas y después de tanto
deliberar se para uno y dice saben que
tenemos que ir porque nuestro pueblo
necesita el ejemplo y la esperanza de
campeones que los inspiren a que siempre
se puede salir adelante un halo de dios
mío dame por favor más voluntad más
fortaleza sabiduría para poner mi
granito de arena y que nuestra vinotinto
vaya a su primer mundial de mayores y yo
sé que ese primer mundial va a ser
qatar-2022
y saben qué
el deporte
sirve como catalizador de los pueblos
porque los deportistas son personas
comunes y corrientes que simplemente
decidieron ir tras sus sueños y en el
proceso se convirtieron en personas
merecedoras de ello porque tú no puedes
lograr algo que no eres o al menos
mantenerlo y nosotros desde la selección
lidera liderados por el profesor rafael
dudamel nos hemos empeñado en sembrar
valores en los jóvenes para que se
conviertan en ciudadanos de bien porque
para nosotros es más importante que sean
mejores seres humanos que deportistas
porque sabemos que a mejor deportista
mejor ser humano
y también
fantaseó con esta idea
cuando dios hizo al hombre y cuando digo
hombre me refiero al hombre y la mujer
cuando estaba haciendo las partes del
cuerpo a mano y llegó al corazón pensó
en venezuela- saben por qué
porque nuestro corazón es de color
vinotinto muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]